Ever wondered what the innermost desire of
SCP-140, or "An Incomplete Chronicle" might
be?
Foundation researchers took a photo of SCP-140
while it was at rest inside of its vault,
and this was the result:
"A number of ornately-dressed women look on
with approval at an assortment of human corpses
impaled on stakes.
Said corpses include civilians of multiple
ethnicities, soldiers dressed in the military
uniforms of a number of countries and Foundation,
Global Occult Coalition and Horizon Initiative
operatives.
Background buildings are gray and appear to
be made of basalt."
This is certainly one wish we can all hope
never comes true.